is it possible
that the universe is uh many more
dimensions
than the ones we experience as human
beings so
if you look at uh the you know
especially in physics
theories of everything uh physics
theories that try to unify
general relativity and quantum field
theory
they seem to go to high dimensions
to work stuff out through the tools in
mathematics
is it possible so like the two options
are one
is just a nice way to analyze the
universe
but the reality is is as exactly we
perceive it it is three-dimensional or
are we just seeing are we those flatland
creatures
they're just seeing a tiny slice of
reality
and the actual reality is many many
many more dimensions than the three
matches we perceive
oh i certainly think that's possible um
now how would you figure out whether it
was true or not is another question
um and i suppose what you would do as
with anything else that you can't
directly perceive
is um you would try to understand
what effect the presence of those extra
dimensions
out there would have on the things we
can
perceive like what else can you do right
and in some sense
if the answer is they would have no
effect
then maybe it becomes like a little bit
of a sterile question because what
question are you even
asking right you can kind of posit
however many entities that
you want is is it possible to intuit
how to mess with the other dimensions
while living in a three-dimensional
world
i mean that that seems like a very
challenging thing to do we
the the reason flatland could be written
is because it's coming from a
three-dimensional
writer yes but but what happens in the
book i didn't even tell you the whole
plot
what happens is the square is so excited
and so
filled with intellectual joy by the way
maybe to give the story some context
you ask like is it possible for us
humans to have this experience of being
transcendent transcendentally jerked out
of our world so we can sort of truly see
it from above
well edwin abbott who wrote the book
certainly thought so because
edward abbott was a minister so the
whole christian subtext to this book i
had completely not grasped
reading this as a kid that it means a
very different thing right if sort of a
theologian
is saying like oh what if a higher being
could like pull you out of
this earthly world you live in so that
you can sort of see the truth and like
really see it
uh from above as it were so that's one
of the things that's going on for him
and it's a testament to his skill as a
writer that his story just works whether
that's the framework you're coming to it
from
or not um but what happens in this book
and this part now looking at it through
a christian lens that becomes
a bit subversive is the square is so
excited about
what he's learned from the sphere and
the sphere explains them like what a
cube would be oh it's like you but
three-dimensional and the square is very
exciting and the square is like
okay i get it now so like now that you
explained to me how just by reason i can
figure out what a cube would be like
like a three-dimensional version of me
like let's figure out what a
four-dimensional version of me would be
like
and then this fear is like what the hell
are you talking about there's a fourth
dimension that's ridiculous like
there's three dimensions like that's how
many there are i can see like i mean so
it's the sort of comic moment where the
sphere is completely unable to
uh conceptualize that there could
actually be yet another
dimension so yeah that takes the
religious allegory to like a very weird
place that i don't really like
understand
theologically but that's a nice way to
talk about religion and
myth in general as perhaps
us trying to struggle with us meaning
human civilization trying to struggle
with ideas that are beyond our cognitive
capabilities but it's in fact not beyond
our capability it may be
beyond our cognitive capabilities to
visualize
a four-dimensional cube a tesseract as
some like to call it or a
five-dimensional cube or a
six-dimensional cube
but it is not beyond our cognitive
capabilities
to figure out how many corners a
six-dimensional cube would have that's
what's so cool about us
whether we can visualize it or not we
can still talk about it we can still
reason about it
we can still figure things out about it
that's amazing
you